good afternoon and thank you for
attending this press conference today i
am lieutenant commander genie shea and i
will be the moderator for this event
the focus of this press conference is
the unified response efforts for the
orange county oil spill
first of all i'd like to go over some
ground rules please silence all cell
phones and electronic devices
following the uc's remarks we will open
it up for questions
please limit one question and one
follow-up before asking a question
please state your name and press
affiliation
i'd like to introduce the unified
command representatives coast guard
captain of the court rebecca orr
lieutenant christian corbo california
department of fish and wildlife office
of
spill prevention and response and
amplify energy ceo martin wilshere
supporting agencies are the city of long
beach newport beach and huntington beach
i'd also like to
acknowledge congresswoman steele newport
beach mayor avery orange county district
attorney spitzer and orange county
supervisor foley
i will now turn it over to captain orr
good afternoon and thank you for the
opportunity to provide an update on the
unified commands activities and the
spill response efforts to date
i just want to open by saying
thank you to the citizens of orange
county thank you to the public safety
officials and public safety
professionals and first responders the
amazing outpouring of support and
resources
for us to be able to assess what's going
on with this oil spill
and to be able to bring resources to
bear to really attack the oil is is
incredible
and i can assure you that there is very
strong unity of effort and information
flow
as we move through this together in what
is a complex dynamic and evolving
situation
what what we know since we talked
yesterday
we continue to do overflight assessments
of the coastline we know that there is
oil off the coastline many of you have
seen it showing up on the beaches
in the forms of small quantities we call
them tarballs or patties it's a sticky
oil that gets caught in the sand
and that is starting to come ashore and
we're continually assessing that we know
that there is
oil ranging from huntington beach and
now we know as far down as laguna
and and likely moving continuing to move
in a southerly direction based on the
wind and the weather and the currents
we continue to increase our staffing
at our incident command post as well as
our personnel in the field we've uh more
than doubled the level of effort just
since yesterday and those numbers will
go up this includes both the on water
recovery of oil that's floating so
that's that's foil on the open ocean
and we have a fleet of boats out there
that are using containment boom to
isolate that oil and collect it and what
we call skimmers and then onshore we
have shoreline assessment teams
we have four teams out today all the way
from huntington beach down to laguna and
what they're doing is they're they're
walking the beaches they're looking at
sensitive areas they're check checking
we have protective boom this is an
orange plastic boom that creates a
barrier and allows us to isolate and
contain oil
they are checking on those those booming
strategies they're making sure they're
holding and we're deploying additional
resources where we need them so a lot a
lot of effort out on those beaches today
and uh that that is just the beginning
of what is a a sustained and increasing
effort to really be able to to tackle
this oil to pick up what we're seeing on
the beaches i i know these beaches are
incredibly important uh not just to the
residents and citizens of southern
california but to much of the country
i live just a few miles up the road i
use these beaches practically every
single day and i know it's and now it's
a very tough situation to to see the
impacts i assure you that on behalf of
united states coast guard the unified
command our responsible party in state
of california we are doing everything we
possibly can to address this situation
thank you
good afternoon my name is christian
corbo i'm a patrol lieutenant california
department official highlight our office
of spill prevention and response is
actively engaged in the unified command
coast guard and the responsible party to
manage this release and discharge of oil
um
my office is a public trustee for
managing all wildlife and
environmentally sensitive sites at this
time we have
pre-assigned and
and deployed boom at seven locally
sensitive sites
bolsachika ecological reserve
lower
newport
reserve
talbert marsh are some of the examples
at the time we have four scot teams
currently assessing the the footprint of
our release along the shores of the
beaches
and they report back to unified command
every day with those reports we plan for
the following days
how many personnel we need on the beach
what type of recovery methods we'll use
what type of strategies we will deploy
as far as fish and wildlife we have
issued what we call a fisheries closure
from sunset beach all the way down to
dana point
the closure extends out six miles and a
swath of about 20 miles long the closure
basically prevents and prohibits the
take of any fish within those waters
we will have actively patrol patrol
boats from fish wildlife patrolling
those waters advising recreational and
commercial fishermen of those closures
in addition we have collected four
seabirds within our carib network
three of those birds are currently being
cared for by professionals one
unfortunately pelican
sustained
wing injuries which
unfortunately we had to humanly
euthanize at the site
at this time we appreciate your concern
we have that those same concerns we live
in the community we're we're part of
your community and we hate to see this
happen on our shores
we can assure you we're doing everything
we can to this ever-evolving situation
it takes quite a bit of
patience from the public and us to to
adjust our strategies as we get new
information so we appreciate your
patience as well
at this time uh i'll pass it over to the
responsible parties
thank you i'm martin wilsher president
ceo of amplify energy
um first of all i'd just like to say
thank you to the the coast guard the
department of california fish and
wildlife and all the various state and
local agencies that have are allowing us
to help with this effort and
we are fully committed like i said
yesterday to being here through all of
the recovery efforts and and making sure
that we can get this everything back to
normal as quickly as possible
uh when we talked yesterday we mentioned
that we were sending divers out to
examine the situation
on the pipeline since that time we have
examined more than 8 000 feet of pipe
and we have isolated one specific area
of significant interest um we did this
primarily through rov to this point but
we are sending divers down now to verify
some
of what we were seeing via the rob um
there's more information to come but i
think we're we're moving very closely to
a source and a cause of this incident um
like i said yesterday we you know our
employees live and work in this area as
well and that we're you know
deeply concerned by what we've seen
environmentally and and with the fish
and wildlife and and so like i said we
are we're committed to
fulfilling our duty here to
help with the recovery efforts as long
as that may take thank you
thank you to the unified command
we will now open it up for questions as
a reminder we will limit to one question
and one follow-up question so that all
members have time to answer uh ask their
questions
mr wilshere
does your company have the money to pay
for the cleanup
uh yes ma'am well whatever needs to be
done we will take care of it
so can you give us a little bit more
depth about that
um obviously you know we as a you know
public company we have
significant insurance in addition to our
funds on hand as well and what did your
rov see specifically um
at this time i'd rather not uh comment
on that like i said i think in the next
24 hours we will be able to provide a
fulsome update um that will
give you all those details
i think we are verifying what we've seen
via the rov yeah
we've seen a spot that we think
could very likely be the source yes
that's correct and is
like i said well like i said let's i
want the divers to go down to the area
before we come in further are they down
there
they will be down there this afternoon
is there suspicion that the leak was
caused by the anchor of a ship is that
something that you're looking into
that is one of the distinct
possibilities yes
um can you tell us when was the last
time the pipeline was inspected and
where is it monitored from is it
monitored from houston or is it
monitored no we have a local office that
is responsible for all
operational uh related to the assets
that we have in the world we have people
in the office in long beach and we have
over 100 people that work with platforms
so um it is cleaned weekly um
there are
and just clarify
yes ma'am um it is a crude oil pipeline
so you know you clean it weekly to
remove any um paraffin or anything else
that may build up and then every other
year there are two there's kind of
alternating yearly schedules for kind of
what we would consider what i call
reference yesterday was a smart pig
which measures the um the
basically the
the inside of the the pipeline so you
run the pink right through the
pig it's
you run this smart pick and it measures
the wall thickness and like i said
yesterday in nine years of only asset
we've never seen any degradation of the
pipe from the inside and then every
other year and those alternating years
we do a full rov scan of the entire
pipeline from above
to see if there's anything laying across
the pipe and so
we did the last smart bag in late 2019
in the last rov scan and last summer so
please give us a timeline for when
um
that's correct and basically we
the boat noticed this the
machine immediately contacted the
platforms and the platforms and
instantaneously started the incident
plan we have
annual spill drills that basically in
correlation with the agencies we're
working with now um that basically you
know
are intended to cover any potential
incident like this obviously you hope to
never have to use them but you know we
are we instantly you know started
notifying all the relevant agencies and
getting the incident
plan in place
it was within that 30 minutes or so time
frame but prior to the she was elite
detected on friday night
we were not aware of a leak on friday
night
we um
we were looking into like i said we were
we looked at the um
we were going during a line run on
saturday morning which is when we
detected the machine so you don't have
equipment that could detect a leak
sooner than seeing a machine can you
explain how you might detect it without
visibly seeing it like i said there is
some um
you know um
equipment that helps to do that um we
did not
have any notice that there was a leak in
the line
we did not
i'm not sure it's you know it's a crude
line um you know i know they smell
methane that's not likely to come from
this but like i said it maybe there's
confusion in the smell but like i said
obviously there's a
it seems like it's correlated mr
wilshere going back to that that's a
reminder man we're going to stick to the
ground rules established so one question
and one follow-up question
like i said until we get down there with
divers i'm not going to
speculate on that
we are investigating and like i said
within the next 24 hours we'll have a
much better answer
yeah essentially the all of our spills
are based on a the number that you guys
occurred to this point is based on a
maximum
of what could be potentially spilled in
an event like this it is not an actual
spill number it is a maximum of what
could potentially be spent
so
we are determining that and like i said
we will update when
we can is it still
no we have gone over the entire like i
said the entire 8 000 feet and there is
no active leak that we are aware of and
especially in that specific area that
we've we've identified and there's no
indication whatsoever that there's
anything further coming from that lake
it
is
311 barrels which then you convert to
gallons which is what you guys have seen
a lot of
around uh you know 42 times 300 is
around 127
if you repeat that i couldn't hear the
answer to the last question um he was
asking what the maximum amount of you
know the like i said that's the number
that's being kind of widely recorded um
is the 311 barrels which roughly
converts to around 127 000 gallons
based on ideology
so if you look behind us you can see
that there's a massive number of uh
ships out here in the huntington
anchorages and the anchorages off the
san pedro bay port complex and um
uh so so there are vessels in the area
uh
precise look at exactly where those
vessels are relative to what mr wilson
is speaking about is an assessment that
is pending and then to your question sir
about uh trajectories so what we are
doing uh is is flying daily overflights
three or four flights a day
where we are mapping the oil and mapping
its direction
looking at models of weather so tides
and currents and wind
so that we can determine the direction
it really is dependent on the prevailing
weather conditions but
the oil continues to move in a southerly
direction and
what we've seen is oiling just down to
dana point a little bit a little bit
southerly at dana point and it and the
trajectories indicate that that trend
could continue if the weather continues
in the current fashion
based on that trajectory
we already have oiling coming ashore uh
but there is oil that remains offshore
and that oil could continue to move
for the coast guard how do ships know
where they can draw banker
uh so the the marine exchange of
southern california in partnership with
the coast guard vessel traffic service
uh makes determinations on the locations
of anchoring of these vessels and
they're guided in to
locations where they drop anchor and
then they are monitored but they take
into account things like where there are
oil pipelines they could get
absolutely uh all of those things are
designated on on charts nautical charts
have we had an incident ever where an
anchor has hit a pipeline
i am not familiar of an incident here
these container ships are waiting to get
into the report
correct if any one of them could
potentially be crossing over
an oil pipeline is
so these uh these ships are uh anchored
and many are awaiting entry into the san
pedro bay port complex the ports of los
angeles and long beach
and uh in the course of transit it is it
is possible that they would transit over
a pipeline
so we're going to stick to the single
questions
so on friday
we did it via rov over 8 000 feet of
pipe and so
we did not we were not aware of anything
friday night like i said
saturday morning
we when we found the sheen that's when
we kicked in the instant command like i
said so we were not aware of anything
friday night if there were reports like
i said they did not come to us and we
did not make any reports
police department friday night with such
an overwhelming response that um
repeat the question
yeah
um
on friday evening
that they were looking into
the cause of the snow but it wasn't
until 24 hours later that
a response was made or issued
what
the notification the coast guard
receives comes from the national
response center and that can be
triggered by a number of different
inputs into the system and then and then
we we receive a official notification
that categorizes the nature of this bill
and then we begin our investigative work
we receive that on saturday morning so
who dropped the ball between friday and
saturday
i can tell you when the coast guard
received the court report which was
saturday morning
uh those reports come through the
national response center
which is a center that's designed for
the reporting of releases of
hazardous material and discharges of oil
so should newport beach have
reported this to the to either the coast
guard or to the amplified on friday
night what happens
to the official report
i i
suspect that newport beach did make
notifications and those were channeled
through uh different channels we can
certainly follow up with you on who made
the report to the national response
center
and when that was the exact time of when
that came into the coast guard but that
was saturday morning is this under
investigation by the uh retirement
office uh yeah we're actually gonna be
talking to the ic we'll have uh
questions
could someone clarify how many square
miles are currently covered by the oil
shield
yes i can take that question so so i've
seen a number of different numbers being
reported 13 square miles 20 square miles
i think when we hear that number there's
a tendency to think that there's a 13
mile
sort of slick of oil that's out there i
i overflew
yesterday we flew up and down the
coastline here and
that i would characterize the oil as
sort of isolated ribbons or patches of
oil so it does uh cover several miles
and that is constantly changing um so i
i think the best way to categorize it is
an area from huntington beach down to
just south of dana point that extends a
couple miles offshore and within that
there are ribbons or pools of oil but it
is not it is not
one sort of large oil slick that's
covering this large large area of
do you have any miles questions
so just on the timeline it's uh it's
it's too early for us to give a precise
timeline on the extent of the cleanup as
the oil continues to move the area
expands
uh so it is going to be a sustained
effort and we are throwing all the
resources we can at that it is a
combination of on water resources right
now we have 14 vessels on the water
that are hired by what we call oil spill
response organizations along with coast
guard assets that are on the water
those vessels are using boom to contain
or trap the oil and then that's picked
up and recovered by skimmers
the other part that's going on is the
aerial surveillance which is a key part
of how we
how we vector in resources on the water
to be able to pick up that cooled oil
that we're seeing
then we have the onshore resources and
and that is very much uh manual labor
where it is personnel that are in the
right level of protective equipment that
have the proper hazardous materials
training and they are picking up patches
pieces tar balls and patties as we call
them of oil as they see that and then
that's being collected for a safe
disposal how long will the beaches need
to be closed
how long will the beaches need to be
noah is involved and leading our
determination of trajectories for the
spill ma'am how long will the
beaches continue to spread out
right well as it dilutes it's a better
option for us right it's not
concentrated toxicity levels for uh what
we're really concerned about is
shoreline impacts at the moment um we've
got pre uh boomed areas and some sites
that we're trying to deflect oil from
these areas undoubtedly we're going to
have oil on the beaches we're trying to
prevent that as much as we can but as
you all seen we have reports of oil on
beaches
it's it's something we can't avoid at
this point is
so the scat teams go out and assess each
day and they report back to the unified
command each day and they basically give
us a coverage of oil on those beaches
they come back with strategies on how to
clean those beaches how much personnel
they may need what type of equipment
and also they're looking for wildlife
impacts at the same time what's the
worst area right now though
um so huntington beach newport beach
areas have been i think most heavily
impacted at this time so more
specifically in specific beaches i i
don't have that information but we can
get that information too
do you have time for two more questions
if anyone else would like to answer or
ask questions
it's a process of continual assessment
it would be uh unfair to to promise uh
timeline on on beach opening and beach
closures and uh we're really relying on
our public health professionals to
continuously make that evaluation
uh but i would say for the for the time
being as we continue to see oil come on
shore that the beaches that are closed
are probably going to remain closed
is there any potential
of fire
is there a way that
there's a low probability of a fire just
given the nature of the of the oil and
the fact that it's been in the water and
um there's a process called weathering
that happens and when the oil shows up
on the beach it's often it's very uh
sort of tacky and covered in sand and a
very very low risk of flammability
that's all the time we have for today
for further questions please email our
joint information center at inquiries at
socal
spillresponds.com again that is
inquiries at socalspillresponse.com
the incident commanders will be
available
after this press conference for
additional questions thank you for your
time
while we're set up can we get the local
officials to come before the mics
katrina foley michelle steele todd
spitzer mayor avery these are our local
officials and we'd love to ask them some
questions because there are boots on the
ground yes and that is correct and we're
actually going to have it be a separate
um event but we have them
all set up
thank you thank you it's a lot easier if
we just do it now thank you we deserve
that thank you very much todd you want
to start us off yeah i should probably
take this down though because i'm not
speaking on behalf
i don't want to be misunderstood that
i'm a representative
because i have some very strong things
to say
um
so good afternoon my name is todd
spitzer t-o-d-d s-p-i-t-z i'm the
district attorney of orange county
my jurisdiction extends three miles out
uh everything after three miles out is
under the jurisdiction of the federal
government
so today this press conference i want to
thank the good work of the coast guard
and
to our parks and uh
individuals all the people that are
really working hard with fish and
wildlife
the number one priority right now
is to save animals and save wildlife
that is the number one concern
but what everybody wants to know is
who's responsible and how did it happen
who's going to pay for it and who's
going to be held responsible
and mr wilshere did speak on behalf of
the company but i was incredibly
disappointed about what i heard from him
he indicated today that his divers his
divers are going to go down and try to
determine the location of the rupture to
the pipeline
if that is not done independently that
is a travesty
the company should not be responsible
for leading its own investigation with
respect to the hundreds of millions of
dollars of devastation that it did to
our environment and our economy we are
going to feel the impacts of this oil
spill for generations i just drove to
the headquarters of mr wilshere's
company
and i will tell you
it took a security guard
to get me in through that lobby and what
i'm telling you is they should have
provided as much security for this
pipeline as they are for their building
in downtown long beach
to already be on record and he did infer
it don't mistake what he said it is a
probability that it could have been a
ship anchor i want you to think about
that for a second every ship has gps we
know the location of every ship
and it will be the investigation a
lawful thorough transparent
investigation conducted by independent
investigators or
a federal governmental agency
it will be independent investigators or
federal or county investigative agency
which will independently determine the
cause of that rupture
as a district attorney depending on
where my jurisdiction ends up settling
whether it's my jurisdiction or the
federal government's i can tell you that
what i heard today
cannot happen it cannot happen you must
go to the federal government let me
unders let me make something clear the
presentation today were from the good
people that are responsible for dealing
with the oil spill
the extent of the spill and how to save
wildlife it did not in
include the investigators
and so let me tell you how this broke
down because i went myself
in downtown long beach
they have the individuals who are
working
the
deputy warden assistant warden they are
doing the cleanup effort and that
command center is in downtown long beach
they have not yet set up a command
center for the investigative
investigation
that has not been established i have
dispatched and have assigned from my
environmental unit district attorney
investigators to be part of that
investigation and as soon as i leave
here i'm picking up the phone with the
investigator who's in charge of this
operation to demand not insist not ask
to demand
that they get this squared away before
that company puts divers down on that
pipeline today they shouldn't be able to
go anywhere near that pipeline
they are biased they're self-interested
and they're going to do everything they
can to try to reduce their damages
and no one should touch that pipeline no
one from this company it must be done
independent and it must be overseen by
either coast guard divers or orange
county sheriff department divers but it
must be independent and corroborated
and i didn't hear any of that today and
that is not satisfactory as your
district attorney so i will say this
let's make it very clear what today's
press conference was it was about from
your speakers
how they are dealing with the coverage
and the spill itself
not this was not the team that is
overseeing the investigation
and i'm begging you
as as the media to call immediately and
find out
why in the world would they let the
company divers go down there and look at
that pipeline without any oversight
maybe there is
but i better be wrong
because they cannot be allowed to touch
that pipeline so if your office isn't
investigating who is okay
yes so
basically how the unified command works
in california it's a multi-agency
response group that contains the coast
guard the state california fish and
wildlife and the responsible party they
are part of the unified command the
investigation is completely separate
they do that purposely so it's not
compromised by the response
so we have you heard from lieutenant
corbeau today from fish and wildlife he
is the responder for the unified command
we have a totally different group of
game wardens and lieutenants that
are working with coast guard
investigators a federal investigation is
underway as well
and so there is a total full
investigation and once that
investigation is complete
mr spitzer's office will get a full
report and
this is a criminal case and so
i just don't want anybody to get the
misconception that there isn't an
investigation there is a federal and
estate investigation separate from this
response these people don't even come in
the same building
right but just to clarify what the
district attorney said we heard from
martin wilshere that his divers are
going down and they've located an area
where there may be a leak what mr
spitzer is saying is there need to be
needs to be an independent investigation
into that it appears that the company
beta offshore is investigating itself
like i said beta offshore the company
amplify energy has a seat at the unified
command that's the way the the law it's
because they have the resources
to pay for this and to help respond but
the coast guard has 51
of this response so at the table the
coast guard has the final say so any
kind of decisions that are made with
contractors investigators to assess the
pipeline would get the coast guard sign
off
i can look into that
at this time you know i don't have
information about who's doing the
assessment
but i can look into that and find out
there is an investigation underway
though that i said and i'm sure that's
going to include you know assessments of
the pipeline
so there's a federal investigation
and there's a by the us coast guard and
a state investigation by california fish
and wildlife law enforcement
those investigations as i said are
totally separate than what you heard
today
you heard from the unified command
that's leading the response these people
are
you know deciding how to best respond to
the incident to minimize impacts to the
environment and to wildlife that's what
they're here for
they are they are yeah
this point it is a criminal
investigation it's uh it's uh conducted
you know like i said
the report will go to the d.a once it's
finalized
you know i i don't know at this point i
mean it's like i said i'm part of the
response so i'm i'm not privy to what's
in the investigation it's totally
separate i have no contact with him
probably not because it's an
investigation as mr spitzer would tell
you you don't have uh people disclosing
information about the investigation
until it's complete mr spencer could you
address what potential criminal charges
you might be looking at here
i can tell you real quick it is it is a
it's it's against the law it's i believe
it's code 5650.
so let me just i have so under my
jurisdiction i have local charges that
are under investigation
for discharging unlawful discharge
hazardous material into a waterway
the a killing of an animal because of
toxic substances that were discharged
into the waterway
the charges i can bring as a local
district attorney if i don't have the
primary jurisdiction of the actual spill
are going to be somewhat limited
again i'm here to make the following
point that orange county district
attorney's office
is deeply concerned
about the wildlife impact that has
occurred on our shores and the economic
impact to our community and somebody's
going to pay for that
criminally or civilly and what i'm
telling you is is i have i have assigned
district attorney investigators
to work alongside with the federal
investigators in order to
help shape the investigation
but what i'm alarmed by
is and you heard eric say this
presentation today was one side of that
discussion which is important how to
deal with the spill how to reduce
damage to wildlife and property but
what i didn't like what i heard was from
the company and what i'm telling you is
the head prosecutor in this county that
is not an acceptable answer and even
though with all due respect he's doing
the best he can he doesn't work for that
side he's right there's that side which
is in downtown long beach and there's an
investigative side which is not yet set
up a command center and what i'm telling
you is is that no diver from mr
wilshere's company should touch that
pipeline until it is absolutely clear
what federal agency is going to dive
that pipeline itself and come up with
its own independent opinion if for
example
that pipeline rupture was in the three
mile buffer where i have jurisdiction
then i'm going to demand that answer i
don't know at this point if i have
jurisdiction but i'm going to be
alongside the federal investigators to
ensure that it's done appropriately and
what i heard today at least from mr
wilshere not from the federal government
is i was not satisfied at all with his
answers
yeah so chip i have jurisdiction from
the consequences of what
happens from three miles again
correct so like damage to wildlife
discharge in our back bay we have
jurisdiction but again if it turns out
that the federal government because the
situs was beyond three miles we are
fully willing to be cooperative with the
federal government to make sure it's a
unified prosecution
but what i'm telling you is i need to
pick up the phone and ask the hard
questions you need to ask is why would
mr wilshere's divers be going down there
tonight and who's going to be with them
who's the u.s attorney's office here
right now
do you know for sure whether it is
beyond that three mile
limit
we know nothing
right the only thing we've heard is from
the company itself
and what i'm telling you is in
investigations
you trust but verify i mean we need to
determine independently what happened
how it happened and who's responsible
and guess what i'm not going to take the
company's word for it is that shocking
i'm not taking the company's word for it
are you saying that you could
potentially bring a civil action
and or of criminal action
that me against individuals or the
company
everything is on the table at this point
there's civil and criminal potential
liability i'm not going to and please do
not report that i'm speaking on any way
or on behalf of the federal government
we just have to determine what the
situation is of the rupture and that
will help determine jurisdiction however
for things that are happening inside the
back bay and then our harbors that is my
jurisdiction as the local dna
i have offered
and it has been accepted by the head of
the investigation side
on the federal state side to allow my
d.a investigators to be there at the
table to participate and i insisted on
that and it was accepted because we
don't know yet
we don't know the extent of the
investigation and it could have
significant and dire impacts for orange
county and the jurisdiction that i cover
supervisor foley can we go back to the
timeline a second can you tell us
because this is your district what were
you told and when
so
thank you so i actually do think that
one of the pieces of the investigation
needs to be
the timing of when there was a report to
the company about a potential spill
my office has been informed that that
occurred friday night nothing to do with
smell by the way but having to do with
uh
mariners and others reporting that there
they saw a sheen and so they
there is information and i would
encourage you to you know do your job to
get public records act requests to find
out
whether or not any local agencies
received reports of a sheen and how they
responded because there was response to
the uh company on friday night and then
because it was dark as i am informed
they went out first thing in the morning
with the coast guard and that is why the
morning incident was confirmed so that
is my understanding and but all of the
investigation will reveal
what the timeline actually is factually
and i'm very careful you know we're both
lawyers but i feel very uh
concerned about expressing commentary on
facts that are being investigated until
we have actual evidence so i'm not going
to office receive reports on friday
night
not on friday night since then i have
received reports i do want to address
the smell because there
there's been a lot of mix up about what
people were smelling
on thursday and friday
the newport canal had a lot of odor
coming out of it nothing to do with an
oil spill but because the canal was
blocked
and
i'm sorry
oh i'm sorry you guys the state parks
actually just said we need to shut this
down
do you guys mind if you just take it
offline they just want to they just want
their facility how about five more
minutes
okay we'll talk to the state parks
are you talking
my name is eric eric laughlin
l-a-u-g-h-l-i-n
and i'm one of the public information
officers for the response
i think our priority is we're going to
just make everything clean and we're
going to make our community
can you please speak louder our priority
is that we're going to make all these
beaches clean and we're going to just
protect our communities safe
i send a letter out to president biden
to declare
that a major disaster
declaration and i did the same thing to
governor newsom this morning and you
were talking about the funding that
responsible parties are responsible for
all the costs to clean up and on the top
of it
economic impact for individuals and
their houses and their businesses but we
have another that it's under the oil
what is that
oil pollution act so responsible parties
have to pay for it but that money is not
really there then we have another one
oil spill liability trust fund
that you are paying actually when you
pay you know you buy gases and that
money can kick in up to one billion
dollars and on the top of it when govern
president signed the declaration that
fema and sba comes in to
compensate the businesses and house
courts and individuals so that's what we
are
doing you know what we have to really
clean the beaches right now so that's
the most important thing that what we
have to do right now thank you very much
for all those you know these
responsibilities that you just
if they don't have enough money to pay
then this trust kicks in just to be
clear
so all these employees
amplify energy and
that beta offshore they are responsible
to clean up all the shores and clean
everything on the top of they have a cap
of 130
million dollars to pay for all the
damages for businesses and individuals
brad yeah i'd like to hear from you
thank you
all right good afternoon on behalf of
the city of newport beach we'd like to
thank the u.s coast guard for their
response and certainly the department of
fish and wildlife and all the other
responders
and i have fire chief boyles here and he
also is overseas lifeguards and he may
have some information about i know some
of you were interested in the timing as
our residents reported out
smelling
uh gas and just so you know we we get
these reports often in the city and it
comes from different sources and cheap
oils but brad before you leave you're a
veteran mariner and i know that you
drove through a big slip can you just
share your personal experience what time
is that was that saturday
yeah i was coming back in catalina with
my family and we were going along we're
going over the air show we're about five
miles off out here
and uh we had some dolphin on the bow
and uh we
uh all of a sudden went into a patch of
thick oil which was
pretty
disturbing and uh we
altered course and started it was
irregular so we steered for the areas
where it was clear
but i would like to get just two coils
up here to just discuss this further on
the timeline of us getting the
information from our residents and then
ultimately uh sending out a release
thank you
speak for that thank you your book right
right i'm sorry i'm sorry he wasn't on
board
uh
yeah so we uh
it was right around noon on saturday
yes
and you were unaware that there had been
a spill i heard various reports on vhf
but you get those frequently from people
as they go along and maybe a boat pumps
and spillage or the ship does some sort
of discharge so i wasn't prepared for
what we ran through yeah what was your
reaction when you saw that well it was
you know
it's an environmental
serious issue
so yeah and it was i've never seen like
it here down here
and obviously santa barbara's over the
years has had several of these
situations happen one much larger
thank you
my name is chief coyles newport beach
fire department last name b-o-y l-e-s
and i just want to reiterate what
supervisor foley was saying with regards
to the smell we did receive multiple
reports over thursday and friday up and
down the coast from huntington beach and
newport beach
lifeguards police officers and
firefighters they were all unconfirmed
which is pretty common every month or so
we get some different methane type of
smells sometimes with receding tides so
it's not to lead into where the smell
came from or when we found out the city
of newport beach officials officially
found out sometime around noon that we
had an oil spill that was headed our way
off the coast of huntington and that's
the only information
on saturday on saturday yes
thank you